in the history of american immigration
one story was commonplace
people who'd been tailors and
seamstresses in the old world finding
new opportunity in the clothing industry
here in new york
well that story continues today with a
modern twist await walda gabrielle hails
from ethiopia where his taylor father
inspired his love of fashion the family
was driven from their homeland but now
the young designer is the force behind a
hot new clothing line affiliated with
saks fifth avenue department stores and
he's living just as real an american
dream as those early immigrants
it's called the papa
where one established brand in this case
lalene and soho new york lend space to
another showcasing their wares and it
helped many businesses bounce back from
the pandemic or even launch them
it's how always walled to gabrielle get
ready started selling his line of casual
gender neutral street wear everyone that
has been buying our hoodies
is someone that has cared about the
community like we do but these aren't
your parents sweatsuits a blend of 50
regenerated polyester and 50 cotton
these pieces retail for about two
hundred fifty dollars and he says with
good reason so there's a silk sheen on
top of all of our products they're made
in america with sustainable fabrics that
employ local new york garment workers
they're selling they're talking about it
like did you touch it did you touch this
cmo alex st urban says customers love
the feel but also the story because
there are a lot of other hoodies on the
market so really focused on getting the
press out there without its rich story
as well as connecting with consumers and
pop-ups in more word-of-mouth spreading
and the inside there's such beautiful
fleece that's just oh yep
yeah this is the reaction that i live
for
right when the pandemic started i
thought about a quote that my dad used
to tell me that i'd completely forgotten
and it was always look out for people
with greatness in their hands
i started thinking how are tailors like
my dad doing how are they surviving how
are garment workers doing how are
pattern makers doing we started this
brand with one mission which was to
support people that had been forgotten
it's been a winning ethos like the name
he bears victory in his native language
wow this is an american dream i don't
know what it is his biggest win securing
space on the avenue as in saks fifth
avenue
oh
my
god
do you think you'll continue to use the
brand name on the garments in the future
i i believe so louis de jacomo is the
senior vice president of menswear when
we all first met a wet we were just
immediately captivated by his his story
his personality and we immediately you
know wanted to support his brand vision
and launch him exclusively at saxon
avenue it's been quite a ride for the 30
year old born in ethiopia and raised in
atlanta he moved to new york city six
years ago for a master's program he then
got a job with the united nations office
of philanthropy
that's when the idea of fashion design
really took hold and the promise of not
only living out his dream but that of
his father he was destined like his
father to be a farmer he ran away from
home from an arranged marriage and went
to the bustling city of addis ababa
which is ethiopia's capital all he kind
of knew was how to fix clothes how to
hem clothes from people and just try to
make a living that way and he wanted to
hire people that had the same kind of
skills when he was building his
tailoring shop he had to leave all of
that behind yeah in 1998
it was all gone with a knock on our door
you know soldiers had come
in ethiopia and said it's time for you
to be removed after the war broke out
between eritrea and ethiopia his family
was forced into refugee camps in eastern
africa in 2000 they earned asylum from
the u.s
hardships that continued to drive him
along with memories of his father's
impeccable style
i never saw him in jeans first of all
all my life he was dressed the nines
suit handkerchief jacket coat
everything he exemplified how we should
present ourselves into the world
and while his uniform is a lot less
formal it has made an impression
walder gabrielle's pop-up strategy led
to his most important connection yet i
never said no to any pop-up opportunity
and finally someone that
knows someone that fished with kenneth
cole the fist with kenneth cole
i didn't know kenneth cole fish he's a
big fisherman he's a big fisherman was
like have you heard about this brand he
said he would like to meet us when we
met him it was like synergy for us
because
he's all about business and impact
kenneth cole's activism during the 90s
aids epidemic led the way for other
brands to attach themselves to causes
and he hopes his young protege builds
upon the philanthropy he's already
started you can't just talk about it you
have to do it you know and he is
committed to sustainability and he
cares about mental health which is
something i'm working on at a certain
point i just become a cheerleader that's
what people want from brands now is that
they want to be proud to be
labeled
in your name as a brand but on top of
that they want to make sure that they're
a part of a bigger impact
and for waldo gabrielle a much more
personal realization
what do you think your dad would have
said
if he saw this
first of all i don't know if my dad knew
what a hoodie was
and it's certainly not the man who who
ironed his pocket squares he didn't know
what a hoodie was but he knew what
craftsmanship was and i think he would
be extremely proud that i put so much
thought in such a simple product and
then also that the name he said was a
powerful name is one that you know will
give a lot of people hopefully the same
kind of confidence that it gave me
so sustainability mental health but this
is a man who started his business this
small little business by donating to
garment workers he's even donated to the
ukrainian cause what he has planned for
next he's going to expand his line
outside of just the livewear casual set
jackets and other accessories sure to
come later on this fall look it's
amazing and i know they're people going
oh my god that much for sweatshirt don't
get me wrong but here's the thing if you
wear that sweatshirt a lot do you
realize how much how cost effective that
is and you have to have the money for it
seriously oh it felt great did you not
i saw you yeah like it was cool yeah i
do not own one so i can't i did not try
one on but i have to say uh the feel of
it was pretty
pretty spectacular all right we've got a
lot more coming up for you